and mike said i'd like to pray with you
and and i said uh okay no problem and if
i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to be on as long against
mike tyson and badujak praying what a
beautiful sight it is no mike tyson oh
my god he could be praying where's
where's mike oh yeah imagine mike tyson
uh competing uh competing with women
right and he was in the yeah he respects
the religion right as opposed to what a
non-profit muslim but i'm not practicing
like it's not like a jacket that you
wear on on saturday and sunday and then
and badou badou will pray at an airport
he'll pray on the plane no
no
can something that small can all the
technology that we have now
logan
paul yeah mike tyson wanted me to fight
him uh-huh that had a sign on on the
door that said no muslim no black people
no dogs yeah or whatever like a rumor so
it went viral
subhanallah you know it's gonna die but
you never think it's going to happen
that soon and when i buried him i mean
and that was three months ago oh we made
it we're on the dean show
the deed the the
show
[Music]
we got some special guests in town
alhamdulillah and these are the first
after all the madness that's going on we
got people actually in the studio you
know we're doing a lot of virtual over
the over the web but alhamdulillah we
got our brothers go ahead and subscribe
right now hit that notification bell
help us get our numbers back up did you
know that
many years ago the dean show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel currently known as digital
minbot so we're trying to get our
numbers back up because the channel at
that time got closed then we started the
official d show channel we're trying to
get our numbers back up to where they
should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442 we should be
over a million subscribers
help us to get our numbers back to where
they should be with that small setback
that we had many years ago you guys can
help us by subscribing right now and
hitting that notification bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show
and don't forget to support us on our
patreon page here
abdullah
salaam alaikum
how are you brothers doing i'm good
great great i'm good thanks for having
us thank you for uh being with us on the
ding show alhamdulillah we made it we're
on the dean show
[Laughter]
so badly jack two three time two three
time world champion i was two but it
should have been three she's been
fighting i should have been five five
should have been five but two times i'm
and amir abdullah you're actually
undefeated
abdullah for the night yet muslims i
know correct i don't know that that
means servant of god yes sir the creator
of the heavens and earth beautiful name
thank you so you're from swedish descent
yeah my mom is swedish and uh i grew up
in sweden and my dad is from gambia in
west africa yeah
okay look this is kind of old i want to
get into this and we'll kick it off from
here ah the infamous prayer video
so that's actually you right there yeah
and for the record i want to clarify
that i have more than just this shirt
the fact that i'm praying with it there
and i'm wearing with it here i do wear
more than just one shirt
okay
we're very clear on that
to start this off
from time management is very important
it takes a lot of time yeah you want to
be efficient picking out shirts yeah
it's like peter griffin on family guys
the same outfit as long as you watch it
so you're good yeah
okay so god what's going on here give us
like okay so we were actually uh badu
and i we had our families we were
vacationing in big bear california
and then uh
mike and his team reached out and they
said hey you know you guys want to come
down and uh
oh no we were getting ready for the
tyson jones fight yeah we're getting
ready for the tyson jones fight yeah so
they said you want to come down and
we'll do a promo shoot this weekend and
i said perfect we're in california so
it's you know a short drive down
uh so we drove down we had the teams all
meet us we went down there mind you this
was for the mike tyson vs roy jones
promo shoot so as we were getting ready
baidu was about to get geared up mike
was starting to get miked up
baidu says did you pray
and i said no i haven't yet and mind you
because we're traveling
and mike said i'd like to pray with you
and i said okay no problem and then
there was people those cameras
everywhere around and
and and they asked mike and they said
are you sure you're okay being filmed
doing it go don't worry about me ask
them if they're okay with it and i said
no of course you know we're okay with it
it's a good form of dawah it's a great
form of dawah to be able to show that
you're listening i mean you have two
world champions there praying with me
mike tyson
world champion he's a world champion too
he's just humble in kickboxing um but we
have you know you have these two
recognized global champions mike tyson
and badujak praying what a beautiful
sight it is um and we prayed before
before you know it was the end of
between
so
um
it was funny at that time i said man i
don't have my pants like okay it's okay
and i'll just pull my shorts down a
little bit to make sure that at least
covers up to the knee
um but
we made the prayer together and it was
beautiful and and afterwards you know we
talked we talked a little about islam
and and things like that and mind you
mike is a very humble very spiritual
brother which a lot of people don't see
that side
a lot of people don't see that
what what are you saying right now when
you put your head
from the highest point to the lowest
point what are you guys saying right
then and there on subdued you know
that's the closest part that you are and
that's the closest way that you can be
to allah where allah hears everything so
subhanallah
you know of course you're you're
worshiping and you're praising allah and
then anything that i like to spend as
much time as i can in sujud um
and just you know have open
dialogue open conversation dua
uh with with our creator with allah and
um
you know everything over subhanallah
um
is pretty personal you know it's
something that uh that i think that's
the connection that's the most point of
your salah i think that's the most
righteous part of your salah glory be to
my lord the most high glory be
and you are are you ever remiss
in performing this now because with all
the hectic schedules you actually are
now you can get tempted right now being
in this situation to be like hold on
like you know mike tyson is he still
playing is he not
it might be awkward uh what about the
camera crew and everybody there wasn't
none of that you guys were like hold on
like
the pressure's on like are we gonna pray
are we not no we're gonna oh we'll do it
when we get home no no you guys are like
no no we do it on time i want everybody
especially the youth all the people who
are just sometimes just nervous and
scared to take that time out and do they
are actually remiss and making the
prayer you guys weren't no no brother
and badoo badou will pray at an airport
he'll pray on the plane
no no when salah comes in when salah
comes in it's a wrap i mean nothing else
is more important want to say that again
check it out when salah comes in it's a
what nothing else is more important
nothing else is more important
now look here's the thing so we had
badou jack
we had amir abdullah we had
uh we're missing one
moisen no mike tyson oh my gosh we could
be praying where's where's mike oh yeah
mike actually had an interview today um
and he's flying out a little bit later
we'll get them on the dean church
that we can have a bigger jeremiah
so this is a beautiful i want to kick
that off unapologetically in a world now
that i mean this is in your words i
believe you said this is there's a
there's a hit list like on islam on
muslims of course there is what do you
what do you when you guys are you're out
there in the spotlight you know with all
the negative information and you know
the one of the main things the dean's
show
does is trying to help deliver the true
message of islam and declare the many
misconceptions
right so now with you guys practicing
implementing islam and simply islam
means to submit your will to the creator
of heavens and earth for not your
muslims out there
how do you guys deal with that
as far as the negative stuff yeah
personally i haven't seen much like
people always give me uh support and and
everybody is happy for me and stuff so i
don't really see it
the only thing i could think of maybe is
i've been robbed in in the in the in my
fights in the boxing maybe some judges
maybe something like that but other than
that to be honest i haven't really
felt any negative stuff
to be honest what do you what do you
think with all with all the i mean
being in a situation that you guys are
in you know a lot of time mo changes his
name to muhammad and that's why we try
to push off you know to because there's
nothing to be ashamed of islam teaches
you to worship one and only one god the
creator of heaven and earth the same god
that jesus moses abraham worship to be
morally upright to be a good human being
i think a lot of people and maybe more
and so in this day and age because
social media and so much influence and
so-called influencers it's very easy to
get distracted from islam and from the
essence of what the deen is uh but you
know rasulullah prophet muhammad said
and islam started as something strange
and it will go back to something strange
but then he ended it with give the glad
tidings and the best tidings to those
strangers and that's who we are and we
take a lot of pride in that but look at
islam is alhamdulillah you know when we
look and we we contrast it to
christianity or judaism it's the same
source it's the same religion we're not
talking about three different religions
we're talking about one religion from
one source but it was altered in two
other religions where the real meeting
the real essence of what the religion is
and what the message is is islam
you know what we learned in elementary
school wasn't the same that we learned
in middle school it was the same
foundation but it was added on to and
then in high school or in college it's
the same foundation but it's added on to
and that's the graduation between
judaism and christianity and
and uh and uh and islam but you know the
bottom line is we don't call them those
we call them you know
the religion of tahit
of the unity of one of one religion pure
monotheism so this might be heavy for a
lot of people we'll we'll go ahead and
shift off and we'll come back to this
this is such a beautiful topic purpose
of life why you've been created why are
you here but let's go back to this now
uh one thing that you really are into
and i've been into for a long time now
and i see that uh what is it uh you were
waking up every morning with mint basil
dandelion citrus turmeric ginger
uh
nutrition is so important
yes so when i'm in training camp it's a
strict diet i have one of the best
nutritionists in the world
lockhart and elite is the company so
james lockwood is one of my nutritionist
he's amazing so he
helped me to cut maybe 30 pounds before
a fight so yeah he give him some good
juice in the morning healthy clean food
and
it tastes good also so it's not just
boring you know
food like that dry whatever this is the
best food you can think of so i'm i'm
looking forward to the next training how
do you feel because you know i mean this
is so important not just for training
but just for life in general 70
of americans nowadays are either obese
or out of weight diabetes diabetes heart
disease you know through the roof
chronic disease people are multi you
know different medications and the 95 of
this is linked to the food choices that
we make yep right lack of proper
nutrition eating fake foods not enjoying
the tell you about the real foods
correct can you talk about that what do
you yeah you know i mean and again i
think it and sometimes it becomes not
just redundant but it comes overbearing
when you when you talk to somebody that
might not have the level of faith or
amen or just you know any belief at all
to tie it all back into islam but you
say it we i mean subhanallah every
single situation that happens we always
go back to the fundamentals we say man
islam is perfect
we say islam is perfect it teaches you
how to eat it teaches you how not to eat
it teaches you how to clean yourself it
teaches you i mean from going to the
bathroom from dealing with your wife to
dealing with business to dealing with
the funerals to dealing with you know
wealth
the religion encompasses everything um
and and and the food is a part of that
and like you said the play about like
the essence then the food of what it is
he never really he never it was
exaggerated with his food and
extravagant with his food it was always
so simple enough just to fill you know
for your nutrition to keep your body
going so they can keep staying in the
state of ibada so it's huge it's
important and islam encompasses all of
it what do you think right now the
attack on masculinity you know where you
have men
starting to the gender roles being mixed
up and whatnot and now you know the part
of being a man you know what i mean
being someone again a man someone's
compassionate kind loving merciful but
you know just to kind of encourage the
youth and others out there you know i
mean living this lifestyle we talk about
islam you know
so much can be said uh and i just
mentioned some of the great talking
points about mercy love compassion but
about that is the quality of being a
real man and then af lead to being
someone in shape being somewhere you
know the sahaba they were
you know they weren't all lawyers or
they weren't lawyers doc they were
warriors you know what i'm saying and
they were fit they were ready this is
what do you think now we lack in some of
this
i mean you need to do you motivate the
move the youth when you talk to them
about some of this
yeah i guess but um and i don't want
nobody construed is when we say there's
uh there's uh
jocko you heard of jaco he was a former
marine he wrote a book and in his book
he talks about this he talks about the
warrior way and then in a lot of these
terms now because you know there's so
much misinformation about islam as soon
as we say jihad as soon as we say
these things people get the wrong
impressions but this is an american this
is a marine and he's talking about a
true warrior is someone who has good
character noble conduct but at the same
time he could do push-ups pull-ups you
know what i'm saying he fixed his bed in
the morning right yeah you know
again islam encompasses all of that uh
you know i said let me say you know when
you when you when you even deal with
your wife you know you play with her
like a child you be loving funny but she
needs you to be a man you become a man
i think that
you know it's a double-edged sword eddie
and i know you can appreciate this but
you know social media and just being
able to see so many different walks of
life
as great as is it has a tremendous
impact on some of these youth
and to see that it's okay to act in in
such a manner um
look at and and
allah is the judge of everybody i'm not
going to judge anybody in stereotype
anybody and i have three daughters so
um
know badu has a young son and to teach
him how to be a man and the
responsibilities and i see him how he
implements that how he deals with his
son is entirely different how he deals
with his daughter it's actually tougher
to raise a boy than a girl to me you
have to you have to i mean you have to
teach him that hard on him
you have to be hard on us
exactly that the thing is it's too easy
to say well look at so-and-so you know
uh is doing this and so-and-so is doing
this and now today alhamdulillah you
know you can change your gender and
compete in the women's olympics and win
a gold medal being a man so uh imagine
if that was boxing come on man
i think that we let things go a little
bit too far and and the more it gets
watered down the more it gets watered
down it's like you know a big vial a big
jug of pure milk and every day you just
put a tablespoon of water into it and
six months from now you've got a jug of
water yeah and that it's just diluted
and i think that's the essence of you
know what the look and that was actually
something that happened wasn't it there
was uh
a person who got into the mirror it just
happened it just happened right in the
olympics as a transgender
uh a man that that competed in the
olympics weightlifting
he beat all the women
what imagine if that was boxing like but
you can die in the ring what's the
problem now i mean this is the quality
right so let the person come in now they
can't there's anybody lining up this is
a good test of it yeah no we should we
should we should also see you know how
he can carry a child uh-huh
right
right it's it's crazy come on man come
on man i mean that that stuff is it's
too far it's too far man it's too far
women compete as women men compete as
men at least in that part let's at least
keep the sanctity and the the values of
that at least separate and what you want
to do in your own private light you know
that's between you and you imagine mike
tyson uh competing uh competing with
women
right
let's go back to to the video now um
okay so we've seen a lot of people i
know too personally uh one of my
students actually who saw one of the um
well-known
persons out there khabib you guys know
him praying
and he saw him then he saw us praying
and the person this is a brother named
reggie and he's connecting the dots and
this was something that motivated him to
go look into islam further exactly and
then he accepted islam then we also have
at x cartel i did this program with a
brother from in mexico this is a few
weeks back ex-cartel he heard the
brother saying alhamdulillah always
praising not doing the chest bump but
pointing up to the one up above right
so now we're seeing mike tyson brother
jack we're saying amir abdullah putting
you know these guys are athletes world
champions humbling themselves taking the
time out from the rat race like how does
that feel
i'm delighted if i can inspire inspire
anyone that's amazing but yeah i don't
see myself as uh you know above anyone
but if
if i can inspire people that and to
become muslim that's
that's amazing
and and muslim again i always define the
words because people when someone asks
me like you muslim i said hold on what
do you mean by muslim is that what x y
and z said fox news are you talking
about one who is like jesus submitted
his or her will to the creator of the
earth is that a good thing or bad thing
this is a good thing right so that's
what i am right because a lot of times
people get stuck on definitions that
they've cut they projected on to islam
has nothing to do with that so now i
want inshallah the fans of baadu jack of
abdullah to do many people they imitate
the stars in the wrong ways they see the
conor mcgregors and whatnot cursing
swearing acting vile belligerent and
then they act upon that because certain
people are not acting in a way that is
dignified but now if you're a fan of
mike tyson badou jack abdullah put your
head on the ground yeah of course what
about that huh and ask the creator that
has an earth for guidance simple
homework simple recipe what would you
say on that you know when when you when
you
and i'm with you eddie when someone asks
me
are you a practicing muslim that is the
most insulting question somebody can ask
me as opposed to what right as opposed
to what a non-profit muslim but i'm not
practicing like it's not like a jacket
that you wear on saturday and sunday and
then monday through friday you do your
own thing so
you know being a muslim it encompasses a
lot of different areas in your life it's
your character it's how you act it's how
you make others feel in order to serve
allah you have to serve your fellow man
you have to be able to help the people
around you you know in the quran the
neighbor and the rights on the neighbor
are so important what does that mean it
means helping society
you know so if you take if you take
uh you know some some people that that
that
pretend to be muslims and to act the way
that they do and then everybody says oh
yeah that's muslims then we should in
that same context be able to say every
catholic is a pedophile and we should be
able to say every protestant like
timothy mcveigh blows up buildings if
that's what we're going to do but that's
not what it is there's 1.8 billion
muslims around so if you take a group of
a thousand of them and maybe if there's
even that many of them that participate
in the the things that they participate
in how are you labeling the rest of them
ask the muslim neighbor that's living
next to you ask the quran that's going
to school with your children ask them
how they live
and and in terms of our responsibility
inshallah everybody that's listening is
we have a responsibility also because
when
when somebody does something wrong they
go on trial but if a muslim does
something wrong the whole religion goes
on trial and that's how in today's media
and the propaganda that's going on today
when a muslim does something bad they
take islam and they put oh he's trying
to implement sharia allah he's trying to
do this and it's inferiority and it's
you know and there's so much of a twist
to it because that's how they spin it
because when islam is united you see the
true essence of islam there's not one
person that would not accept it
this video
if you notice whose name was it and
where i got it from it was from the
mayweather channel yeah
what's up with our brother uh floyd
mayweather so he actually got to see
this did you guys you trained uh no
that's that that channel actually ran by
yeah it's jeff it's jeff mayweather that
you know we helped manage also yeah okay
so mayweather jeff is what his uh his
uncle uncle okay yeah yeah so uh but
look everybody you know in mind you
floyd's ver he's always in dubai he's in
saudi arabia he's in all this i saw him
one
because he respects the true religion
the essence of the religion
again not the people that propagate not
the people that pretend not the people
that do those things that take away from
what the essence of the religion is but
i mean i am so confident and that's why
you know i have such a strong faith the
more you learn about the religion i
thought i knew islam until i really
studied it i was born muslim
alhamdulillah as everybody is but i mean
i was born and my parents were muslim so
we were raised as muslim
but it wasn't until you know about mid
part of my life where i really started
understanding what islam was and the
deeper i got into it the more confident
i got about
how can you not how can you not just
believe in allah and just under and when
you understand
it's totally different now for some
people who have just heard this for the
first time you
you said allah and some people oh that's
that muslim god the muslim god right
who's allah when you talk about allah
a lot of people get that mixed up that
allah means god it doesn't mean god
that's the name of god that's that's the
entity that's the the supremacy that
that has created everything so when we
refer to allah we refer to god
um
we don't refer to jesus as one of our
you know beloved prophets um we don't
refer to
uh you know idols and we don't have
three gods we have one god
you don't have two ceos in a company you
have one ceo you don't have two
presidents of a comp of a country you
have a president and then you have the
whole staff so
um we refer to allah as god that's
bottom line the creator god however you
want him number one only one this is
many people don't know an encyclopedia
britannica it shows that because
obviously jesus peace be upon him i mean
who you love i love we love many people
don't know that that we love him as a
mighty messenger he would say allah
right elohim allah this is the god of
abraham the god of jesus the god of
moses and when you kind of let educate
people in this it's a whole different
persona right it's it's amazing uh so
let me ask you guys now from from day to
day you know how how's life how's life
for badou jack no you know you got uh
you you're getting ready for what's uh i
heard you're gonna be
uh giving this guy a smack down and then
giving him some dao inshallah logan paul
actually uh mike tyson wanted me to
fight him uh-huh i don't think he's not
interested in fight guys let's get logan
message the
let's get logan paul the message logan i
sent you a message logan you saw the
message i invited you to something
priceless logan i'm inviting you again
and you can i'm sure you watched that
video now we got
badu jack
and he's giving you an invitation what's
the invitation you're a fight promoter
too
no the thing is
i want him to sit and do uh do a a nice
meeting with you guys i think he can
benefit from your friendship
now loaded and we've you know we've
crossed paths a couple of times with
logan because we worked with ksi for the
first fight
and um you know
and you got to give the kid credit you
know i mean he has really turned his
life around and he in he's and he's
maximizing his his platform and good for
him yeah good for him yes uh he's also
been on kind of like a spiritual journey
if you watch some of his has he know
he's kind of been you know talking about
this that and the other and it's
interesting when people go through that
and they turn to uh all these different
things you know um
you have these rocks and then the buddha
and then all the you know different
things superstitions but that's the
beautiful which you mentioned the word
earlier tohid when people really and
i've had so many guests over the years
they've experimented with everything and
anything but when they really got to
experience islam submission to the
creator not to creation then it was like
wow now it's like you got counterfeit
and then you got the real deal right
real thing so that's why if because you
guys have access to many's people man
did you guys ever go out to lunch ever
you know kick it with each other with
the logan paul no no no no no we were
always on opposite sides of the sword
yeah you know we were with the ksi team
okay is that it has that been set now
that's like okay now you can't cross
over it is uh you know i mean
i don't know if it's set set but ksi
beat him right he did yeah you did and
you you helped traino uh i actually
helped train
this was probably 2018. yeah so he
called me it's like a youtube kid that's
going to come in can you please spar
with him or whatever he's huge in the
youtube world i've never heard of him
and then so we did a little video um you
know i dropped him with a body shot uh
no a little sparring just for fun
and uh yeah and then he was like he got
40 million he's one the biggest youtuber
in the world or whatever they're gonna
have a boxing fight against logan paul
and
who i didn't really know either but i
seen his face around but uh yeah and um
and then they fought i walked him to the
ring
he begged he begged me said please i
don't want to get involved in these
youtubers i said please man there's good
marketing and everything else all right
and he's actually a nice kid ksi i
actually like the kid he's very nice
yeah he's a good kid so that goes back
to what i was saying you just have no
idea like from that mexican cartel
uh individual you know who i interviewed
and he's somewhere in mexico with the
cartel and now he's muslim he ends up
accepting islam alhamdulillah you just
don't know what kind of impression in
exactly what you're going to say or do
that can leave a lasting impression on
many people who are watching they're
looking you know your example what
you're saying you know so that's why
every time we post something on social
media you always got to think a little
extra you know it's one thing if we just
us but you gotta i love it the young
kids that does you know following us so
we've got to think before
even sometimes you want to respond to to
haters online but they know you're going
to think about it i'm a muslim i can't
right i can't do it you know masha'allah
allahu akbar and that's not a war cry
that's praising me
this is so important they in in this day
and age when you have just a tremendous
amount
because we're creatures of imitation you
know and that's why god almighty allah
sent the messengers and muhammad peace
and blessed you upon just being the last
the final messenger sent to mankind
and the the beautiful thing is now that
it's just so hard to find great and good
examples nowadays sure who who's my son
my dog who are you going to point them
to you know obviously we have the best
of generations you know but just today
living examples right that they can kind
of relate to so it's important tomorrow
they see like you know brother jack they
see khabib they see people who are out
there trying they might you know look
we're human beings we make mistakes
we're not the best but hey we're you
know in a day who are we going to point
to conor mcgregor
what do you think with the ladies
i'm saying we got too many connors out
there and even look i can't know what's
worse even though we even sent i i
brought an irishman we sent him a
message because this dean is for
everyone doesn't matter you could have
been habi's father actually invited him
before he passed away you know what i
mean that's the mercy of islam what were
you going to say
what's worse than the way conor mcgregor
acts
is the people that try to imitate the
way that he acts because connor deep
down is not a bad guy he's not
believe it or not his manager is a
muslim
who conor mcgregor yes you know him yeah
i do
and and
conor's not a bad guy he plays the game
he plays the role he knows how to market
himself he knows why is he why is he in
the pinnacle right now of the big being
the biggest mma uh fighter even though
his record doesn't justify that because
he knows how to keep himself in the
spotlight he knows what to say to create
chaos and all of that connor's deep down
a genuine guy from those youtubers
you know they know how to create things
floyd mayweather why was floyd the first
billion dollar combat sports athlete
because you know as he got older and you
know when he when he trained they called
the transition from pretty boy floyd
where he was knocking guys out over the
money mayweather where
his body got older and his hands started
getting a little bit more you know
more injured his body started breaking
down he knew that the knockouts weren't
going to sell so he put himself in a
marketing position where people still
wanted to see him lose and he became the
villain
he marketed himself that way but that
doesn't mean floyd's a bad guy it means
floyd's smart enough to be able to
create enough chaos and controversy
where people watch him and like he said
some people most people pay to see me
lose some to pay to see me win but they
all pay
and that's the difference yeah it seemed
like after his fight with khabib
and then he came back to fight i think
it was dustin right and then he was kind
of like he was acting a lot different he
was a little more humble respectful
right which didn't work out too well
yeah now that's the connor that's the
real economy that seemed like he was
being kind of genuine he was thinking
that's the real conor mcgregor but guess
what it so he lost he's like how am i
going to market this fight think about
it i just lost can i really be that same
guy in the rematch no why do people want
to watch that same fight again that was
one of his worst performances the first
time he's ever stopped by strikes
so what am i going to do i'm going to
change the marketing concept the concept
is you know what i'm going to go back to
that guy and that's what i'm saying
what's worse than him acting that way
because he knows what he's doing is
other people thinking that's how you
should act
the imitation is always worse than the
reality yeah and then what happens is
people imitate these people and then
what do you got you got disaster waiting
to happen right right so then you have
look and then just people like that just
going too far you know just recently he
insulted again
that was at first now he's fighting
insulting his father you know what i
mean
how about the whole coronavirus thing i
think very bad you know again i don't
think
because even when even when you know
uh habib's father was alive
you know conor had a lot of respect
towards him
he's trying to keep himself he's trying
to paint himself as the villain and mind
you i don't think you ever crossed that
line i think that's improper there's a
certain way you can mark it but you know
when subhanallah and i say this you know
with all due respect when you don't have
deen
everything's okay
when you have no shame everything's okay
and and again this is another call for
conor to really you know look into dean
to look into the way that what you guys
were doing because i i know for sure no
one can have true peace and contentment
in life if they're not living life the
way their creator created them to live
yeah and based on that video to make it
very clear we didn't say to mike we
weren't inviting him to salah baidu had
asked me did you pray by the way mind
you he asked me it was a private
conversation
and i go no i didn't so then mike heard
it and he goes i'd like to pray with you
guys fitra is alive yeah exactly and the
funny thing about that is it's a video
on there's a rumor online saying that
uh mike tyson and the other champions
uh it was a coffee owner or something
like that that said that had a sign on
on the door that said no muslim no black
people no dogs yeah or whatever like a
rumor so it went viral viral everywhere
everybody's talking about that we prayed
anyway we didn't care and that the owner
was of the coffee shop whatever was so
scared
but it's the tyson's logo in the
background is his own place i don't know
who started that rumor but it went yeah
viral it was crazy these are kind of
friends you need to be around you know
people who like
around you that uplift you you know when
you're getting out of line you know or
they remind you when you're slipping up
those those are the kind of eddie it's a
very a great point if you don't mind me
jumping in yes so we live in las vegas
we live in las vegas you can consider
most people call it sin city we change
it to sunni city right why
the people that we surround ourselves
with and and i call by do a part of my
close community are people that we chose
to be around i have three daughters do
you think i can allow my daughters to be
around people and i'm not saying las
vegas is the epicenter of haram but it's
certainly very
easy to find it
and that's how i met my son i saw my son
called the adam one time in the masjid
and i said i'm yanking him up
i didn't care who he was i didn't even
know he was a boxer
when i saw him in the message i said i
want him in my circle a young you know
and i had him come to the house and
start reciting with my daughters
that's how i got close to my son so i
think that every single one of us should
be able to
create your own community not based on
where you are we live in las vegas
but my daughters when when when it's
time for salah they'll all line up ammo
badu or they call him
uncle badu they'll line up with him and
they'll pray with him and they'll pray
with him it's normal it's standard like
when they see someone pray they're like
oh god what's he doing i remember going
to somebody's house one time
and and may allah you know
if
maybe allah you know bless him the
father didn't pray
so and i didn't know that i didn't know
that the guy didn't pray i so i realized
the mother was the only one that prayed
because when i went to pray
the kid started laughing me because look
he's praying like a woman
so he i realized then that it was only
the mother that prayed in the house so
you create that you create that
community within yourself you create the
community of having the real muslims
around so that your kids learn from them
because your kids will never be better
muslims than you by default unless you
make that happen what's this beautiful
book that you talk about that was sent
for all of mankind
this book that not a single letter has
been changed in almost 1 500 years not a
single letter let alone
a council of
orthodox whatever they are to change and
update
when a book is revealed by a divine
entity that has created everything and
here we are in 2021 with the biggest
technology in the world and we still
can't duplicate something as small as a
fly technology cannot replicate
something as small as a fly a b
the the the
the
the miracles of the bee
can something that small can all the
technology that we have now
duplicate and replicate that so that
creator the person that made that
sent this book of knowledge down sent
this book of what's going to happen sent
this book of a guideline of life
and told you listen i created you for
one reason
the jinn
and the mankind to worship me this is a
test
could you imagine if
i mean if i told you that if you ran you
know a marathon at the end i'd give you
a million dollars you'd spend six months
a year two years ten years training for
it
but we know
knowing that you're going to die like
eddie i can guarantee you you're going
to die but do i guarantee i just buried
my father who was the biggest influence
in my life
subhanallah you know it's going to die
but you never think it's going to happen
that soon and when i buried him i mean
and that was three months ago three
months ago
how was he
82. uh you know he caught kovit and he
just couldn't uh he couldn't get over it
he
couldn't
he was like a 50 year old young soul
he was a good friend
alhamdulillah
so he was such a big and when you see
that is you know he came he went back to
allah
so you know that's going to happen how
do you not prepare yourself for that
like how i
it was what was that um
i remember having my uncle who was the
closest to me
and when he passed away you know he's
going to pass the person i was there
it's a very interesting story like i was
making due i said yeah allah please just
let me get to the um hospital on time
just to see him one last time and as
soon as i got there he ended up passing
away so allah answered my dua
and i kept saying to him you know having
transitionally to repeat you know
but then when he passed i was numb it
was like
compared to like let's say you have a
portrait a family picture and slowly
this person the picture is gone right
and one by one i was literally numb for
like i don't know maybe a few weeks i
just i couldn't it was just a weird
really scary feeling like how did you
feel when you're
till today when i say allah may
may god have mercy on his soul it
doesn't feel normal
it's like i'm saying that about my dad
like i'm saying that about my dad and
and i i my wife and i you know we talked
about the other day i said i'm you know
one second away at any time just a
breakdown i'm still at that ver i don't
think you ever get over that you just
learn how to deal with it
and my father you know mashallah you
know he was here very successful
businessman he made sure that we grew up
very very very
straight on the path of islam i didn't
learn english until i went to school it
was arabic in the household
it was you know islam was in we weren't
in a community that had any muslims
so the islam was just at home so it was
very i was at school eight hours a day i
slept eight hours a day
how much influence i'm going to get from
my father but he was so straight lined
and so insured that you know so
i'm almost militant
but he instilled that islam
but i learned
i think a lot of kids and youth can
understand this sometimes with parents
that weren't born here you can't really
relate to their teaching right
even things in school like when there
was pta meetings where they'd be like
what is this pta meeting like for what
dad all the kids and you know their
parents are gonna be at the pta meeting
don't worry about the pta meeting um
you know things like that sometimes
separate you from the message
she's like well they don't really oh
it's old school it's you know it doesn't
relate to me it's not america it's not
cool it's not all of this and then later
you start realizing you know man he had
it right he had it right and you just
hope that inshallah it doesn't get too
late for that
i've never you know i grew up in i
didn't have one arab one muslim nothing
around me
i never had an ounce of alcohol in my
body never smoked never had you know any
drugs none of that stuff
you you did kickboxing right yeah you
remind me of a of a guy and he was just
out there was a video clip went viral
and he was talking about he's uh i
believe uh orthodox christian
and he was talking about how islam is
the answer for this that and the other
andrew tate and i'm not a muslim right
if i had to choose a religion i would
because i live in an orthodox christian
country i go to the orthodox christian
church i donate twenty thousand dollars
a month to the church in the country
the church the church in romania is very
powerful and i like having church
friends so i give them a lot of money
right so i would guess i'm an orthodox
christian but
if i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to bet on islam
yeah you know andrew taylor i've heard
of the name you've heard him he's like a
kickboxing i've heard of the name yeah
did you see this clip that i'm talking
about no he was praising islam oh
masha'allah yeah yeah um okay so just in
the last uh a few minutes that we have
tell me
look for be it badou jack be it muhammad
ali be it
abdullah be it whoever it is and then
you see certain actions that they do and
say wow this guy's humble oh this guy
you know he's
very altruistic he's this down the other
it's not that those are your you know
because of you and yourself it's all
linked back to the sponsor of that islam
sure so there's something that's
motivated you
to start giving back let's talk about
that before we wrap up this charity
organization
so yeah we started the bad jack
foundation uh to help kids uh give give
them a fighting chance in life whatever
it is you know so especially orphans and
and people you know
in war or whatever it is so
yeah i mean i always done stuff uh you
know before my fights before i really
start praying and stuff just small stuff
helping in gambia whatever sent a couple
of thousand hundred dollars or whatever
and
i'm always been on me is like man
don't do that in in private i said i
want to do everything private i don't
have to yeah but i said but if you if
you we can start a foundation you can
help more people and we can do it big
and raise more money
it's not about uh you know promoting
yourself it's about uh you can help more
people
and then so we he helped me we started
the foundation and then it's going very
good right now so how could people hook
up if they want to help and support this
so they can go to
jointeamjack.com or
badujakfoundation.org
but the premise is just like baju said
he was doing a lot of great things and
of course charity should be done in
private but given badou's platform i
said you know what you can do is
actually help a lot more children by
doing it and actually creating the 501c3
nonprofit organization having donations
come in we can start instead of helping
a thousand kids you can help 10 thousand
kids a hundred thousand kids we had like
yes sorry yesterday the uh event was osp
yeah they were donating ten thousand
dollars to us
to i mean to the foundation
what got you i know we talked a little
bit about this before
when we spoke but what for the audience
that's hearing this for the first time
what got you motivated before because
it's islam that inspired you to give
back but what got you to actually
knowing islam based on evidence and
proof is the truth
i mean my dad is a muslim so
it's everything comes from my dad
so alhamdulillah you're inspired from
from my dad yeah he taught me islam and
and uh ahmed is
one of my best friends now he helped me
a lot
i'm learning every day
and uh yeah everything comes from islam
my humbleness everything
if i'm even humble but
it's other people to judge me if i'm
humble enough but i'm trying
yesterday we were sitting on stage with
mike tyson and he said something that
was just so essential and he said
you know
what
what good is it
this is mike mike tyson we're sitting on
stage with him and he said what good is
it if i make 100 million dollars or 400
million dollars he said but i'm buried
i'm gonna go meet allah
what what good is that for me then how
many people are listening to this well
we had you know we had a few hundred
people and it was a private event but
you know it'll be televised to millions
of people and that was so i mean this is
mike tyson who was larger than life at
one point in his life i i i really feel
you guys being around him this helped to
inspire him too no you could tell
yesterday
he was so happy he was laughing so much
he like when he's around us he's another
person yeah
he's so relaxed again surrounding
yourself with that circle there's the
you know the famous hadith from the
prophet saw some authentic hadith he
said you know good friend is like a
perfume seller
right and the bathroom is like someone
who works with fire with coal right so
what are you going to get you're going
to get burnt if you go with the
blacksmith right but the person who is a
perfume seller you're going to get some
perfume or you're going to leave
smelling good right
that was my next thought
surround yourself with people that you
know pull you down
let's go back to the let's say the
average person 30 years old
if you're 30 years old you have not been
about
seven years old how can i prove it
add up all the seven eight nine hours
you slept for 30 years
out of 30 years out of all the nights
last night you went to bed and woke up
this morning you don't remember a thing
you've been unconscious for about eight
years if you're 30 years old you slept
about eight years
okay
how much traveling have you done in 30
years from the television station to
home to another country to another city
to school to church
you've probably traveled two years your
life has been just getting back and
forth to where you're going so there's
eight years of sleeping two years of
traveling that's 30 years out of your
life before you accomplish anything how
long do you sit in school in america we
stay in school from the 12th grade to
from the first grade to 12th grade same
here yeah
virtually six hours a day yeah
six hours a day for 12 years break it
down you sit in the classroom for three
years
without leaving
okay two years of traveling eight years
of sleeping three years of school how
many movies have you went to how many
wrestling matches how much entertainment
how many movie theaters live plays
baseball games probably two years of
entertainment so by the time a man you
all the people know him bear with us i'm
saying by the time you have children by
the time you have uh made away for your
children by the time you've paid for
your home you're pushing 60 years old
so
life is real short
so you have all your traveling out of
all your sleeping out of all your school
out of all your entertainment you've
probably been half your life doing
nothing so what am i i'm 35 years old 30
more years i'll be 65. we don't have no
more influence we can't do nothing much
at 65 your wife will tell you that
ain't too much more to do
so
did you know i'll be 65 in 30 more years
in those 30 years i have to sleep nine
years i don't have 30 years of daylight
i have to travel back to america take
six seven miles all my traveling and
probably four years of traveling the
next 30 years about nine years of
sleeping
television movies entertainment about
three years of entertainment out of 30
years i might have about
16 years to be productive so it's how we
can all break individual lives now what
am i going to do in the next 16 years
what's the best thing i can do get ready
to meet god all right let's end with
that what do you think your reaction
muhammad ali the great
when he passed away
it was the first person i ever cried for
that i never met
he had such an influence and that's why
is he had a way of just you know he used
that platform he was unapologetic about
who he was whether it was black muslim
whatever it may be he was unapologetic
about that and he had no problem letting
everybody know but look at how true that
is
what at the end of the day i mean what
is all this and mike tyson said it
yesterday what am i going to do with it
all at the end i have to go meet my
creator
what am i going to tell him
what am i going to say to him
that's true
no mohammad ali is it's
like
mike tyson was my favorite fighter
growing up but him just as a person he's
the greatest of all times
just larger than sports boxing was so
small the boxing was his platform he
took that and he jumped up to levels
that
he will in history everybody will know
muhammad ali my grandmother knows
muhammad ali and mike tyson and that's
it and she's not a boxing fan they
transcended the sport amazing and and
beautiful words get ready to meet god
almighty the creator allah i want to
thank you guys again it's an honor and
pleasure to have you guys pleasure as
ours
thank you and again people can hook up
with uh you at the uh for the charity
organization by the jack foundation.org
or on social media on instagram twitter
i mean by the jack foundation well i
bless both you exactly great job with
what you're doing to
everything that you're doing we're big
fans of yours thank you brothers thank
you
and thank you guys for tuning in
we're here every week subscribe if you
haven't already and let's get to it i
mean you have living
living examples today who many of you
admire and they took the highest part of
man took it down to the ground humble
themselves and they in a constant state
of remembering the creator of heavens
and earth and if we can leave with one
thing of homework for you guys do what
they did humble yourself ask the creator
of heavens and earth for guidance and
then what muhammad ali the great advice
get ready to meet god get ready to meet
the creator we'll see you next time here
on the dean show until then peace be
with you assalamu alaikum